and comedian Margaret Cho takes on
racism misogyny and homophobia in her
new book I have chosen to stay and fight
this 30-minute talk contains language
that some may find offensive thank you
very much hi everybody thank you very
very much you know this is totally makes
me nervous now because I didn't realize
that they were gonna have like c-span
you know the book people the book TV
people there I feel so stupid cuz this
is so like I because I'm no Amy Tan so
it's very difficult for me to I deal
with this kind of stuff
hello and thank you and my book I this
is a I've been on this book tour for a
little while and and you know it's very
weird cuz I go on these like morning
talk shows and and you know people are
very nice and they they say oh we love
your book but but tell us what was it
like to make Charlie's Angels they think
that they're being engaging and funny
and cute and I don't want to be mean to
them because I would like to promote my
book I but I really want to go that's
right I just want to say with that
volume and with that intensity right in
their face I'm gonna start doing that if
anything happens like that one you know
I really I feel if I'd like you know
when everybody's you know whatever it's
like this happens to Asian people I
would people go where are you from and
you go oh I'm I'm from Pasadena and they
go no where are you really from I think
at that point you gotta go and it's
gonna be a whole like campaign I think
we're gonna have ringtones anyway but
you know how I respond to that is just
like weird because I never know what to
say in the face of casual racism like
what do you say when people you know are
very casual about it and it's not
exactly racist it's just the only word
that I have for it is um it is just kind
of mistaking me for not an American
maybe making me feel like I'm not in
America
that's something that is continuous
thing that happens constantly I think to
lots of people and but you know I have
to be you know good spirits about it you
know I can't have to say well I don't
really I wasn't in Charlie's Angels I
was actually I was hosting the view at
that point so I but it's weird like this
morning guys these talk show guys like
they they feel so weird to me like I try
to explain things to them on their level
and talk to them about race and you know
to go well could you imagine if there
was only five straight white guys on TV
only five wouldn't that be weird they
can't eat they don't even know it's
there just like mmm you know like they
cook they completely don't understand
what I mean and then they just say you
know when they talk about race they go
well you know what I think Asian girls
are hot that's their racial discussion
that they you know and I'm like okay so
that's our contribution to society some
of us are hot
I guess it's it's it's a weird thing and
say cuz honey sometimes feels like an
uphill battle and you know is it's very
distressing at times and but that's why
I wrote this book it really is to deal
with this kind of problem with casual
racism and also what I think is a big
big concern of mine is invisibility
I feel very invisible in this culture
because I don't see people like myself
with my point of view out there in the
media and I think you know that kind of
causal racism that kind of stuff is
never really addressed and so this book
is for that and it's not just racism
it's also homophobia I think that people
have this weird permission to be
prejudiced towards gays and lesbians be
prejudiced towards certain different
ethnicities different people of color
just because they have this idea that
it's it's okay that we haven't had our
particular civil rights movement yet
that had the power and the scope of the
african-american civil rights movement
so we haven't had the same level of a
civil rights movement in that regard so
I think that's what we need and my book
is a contribution to that so I'd like to
read a portion of it for you
I'd like to read an essay called that
Ann Coulter people get so pissed off at
Ann Coulter when her name is mentioned
in my circles [ __ ] go off I
realize I needed to do some research
generally I'll read anything and agree
somewhat with anybody even extreme or
stupid points of view because anyone who
can get it together to write a book is
kind of cool and the worst the author is
the more I enjoy it it never fails to
capture me in a web of desire I got that
you got me at hello feeling when reading
the foreword for slander written by high
ass junkie pill popper Rush Limbaugh I
can't believe he was able to put
sentences together while on all those
[ __ ] drugs which explains his chaotic
and disturbing point of view and
therefore makes him an incredible idiot
savant I dove into Ann's writing which
was a cross between bizarre accusations
about liberal politicians and
psychobabble hyperbolic lies that make
no sense the conservative men love her
because she is a loyal slave to the
status quo
she is [ __ ] a Kent a as well as
betraying her gender as a notoriously
anti-feminist woman hater
she is also racist homophobic without
compassion inhumane arrogant dishonest
contradictory not funny has an arguing
technique that compares closely to I
know you are but what am I
wears red leather miniskirts and is just
plain [ __ ] wrong
I can't even quote her because
everything she says is too awful for me
to write all this and she isn't even hot
if you're going to be wrong at least be
hot I'm guilty of some of the biases
that an has only in reverse my prejudice
against an hatred of the establishment
the judicial system anti-abortionists
racism misogyny the joining together of
church and state can have be spiraling
downward out of control and maybe my
facts could be discounted and I could be
called a liar as well but I don't give a
[ __ ] because at least I am hot I may not
be pretty in the traditional way but
players line up around the block to make
time with me and they ain't even getting
it right then that's just for the
wristband yo hotness is not about age
looks body type race it's about honesty
knowing who you are and being who you
are without trying to front yourself as
being better than you really are it's
about the down deep authenticity of self
then looking at living it loving it if
an were hot then I could excuse some of
her behavior she only goes to the safe
end of her sex appeal ever so slightly
flossing a North Beach leather mini with
her long legs and crazy anorexic body if
she had some integrity she would go get
some straight-up fat silicone titties
and part her hair in the middle take
some velcro rollers and make those
stripper forehead curls that make the
boys go what's up shorty if she had
blonder bigger hair that certainly would
add credibility to her conservative
politics and her upper class robotic
bigoted never had any [ __ ] come down on
me like a hard rain so why should I care
about anyone but anyone but me he values
she can't spit her ignorant egg Murray
rhymes successfully with that beige
lawyer lipstick and needs to get some
Revlon cherries in the snow the hose
lipstick of choice she's a hoe in
sheep's clothing
and it's about time that she told the
truth the whole truth and nothing but
the truth there's nothing wrong with
docking [ __ ] for the things you believe
in but don't play the thinking man's
bombshell with me because Anne doesn't
think and she's nowhere near being the
bomb I just wish that she'd detonate and
explode but the only way that she could
blow up is to face the 70s porn movie
dick sucking music and own up to her own
politico prostitution I'm a ho for the
people and I love that and I'm proud
because I embrace my ho side and I never
try to pretend like I know everything
about everything because I don't I don't
have to front because I actually care
about people I believe in equality for
everyone all I ask for is that but
that's not possible in the America we
live in today for a million reasons and
being one of them she won't put him on
the glass so she's not qualified to
throw stones
so what I would like to do now is answer
some questions if you have any you could
raise your hand a novel answer yes max
max siren lipstick yes
you know what it it's Mac rocker Matt
Mac Mac makes really good lipstick a
little bit dry little matte but very
Hoey oh you want people to talk into the
microphone
I see so uh do you want to pass it to
who else just back there
hi my mother is doing great
my mother is um she had a heart attack
and this was very scary you know my
mother's really great caretaker and she
spent so much of her time taking care of
other people that she neglected to take
care of herself and then had a heart
attack and it was very very troubling
you know very sad a very scary time and
so now she's recovering and she's doing
much better he's on it she's not she's
on a cruise with my father and she's
skeet shooting but she loves oh I love
to shoot the gun sometimes I so relax
but um you know it's interesting that
the whole thing about making fun of my
mother comes from being asian-american
like I think that most Asian American
kids at some point make fun of members
of your family because they're so
foreign and you can't deal and it's so
embarrassing and it's so just it's so
weird till I kind of live with these
very foreign people because you feel
very American and they're so different
to you so you make fun of them in order
to kind of deal with the culture clash
and that so I made four I've been making
fun of my mother's for like a good
thirty two years and she's never minded
at all she's very good good-natured
about it and it's kind of paid off now
because I'm I'm now developing a
television show for my mother my mother
has her own TV show now she's gonna have
her own show on Fox and it's very
exciting because she has her own sitcom
now and it's it's like this weird thing
you know I did a television show
many years ago All American Girl which
had the first Asian American family on
TV and since then we haven't seen
another family like that on television
and I think that's wrong you know I mean
there's not really very many Asian
people there's on TV though there's the
people on lost
you know them they're always like
staring to see who's gonna shoplift
something from the islands life but you
know that's like all we have and then a
couple people on ER but there's like not
very many and it's just it's just just
depressing and so hopefully you know
this will be a good thing and so the TV
show is starting my mom and she has like
you know I'll be playing her and you
know she's about her that's her family
who she has a son who's uh who's very
uptight and my mother's a very free
spirit and you know he's always like
kind of going crazy because he's very
conservative and you know she's always
going next door to hang out with the
lesbians you know that lived there and
excluding him mommy gonna go the
Michigan Women's Music Festival and you
cannot come so you know I'm looking
forward to it because I'm actually gonna
be a producer on it which is a great and
I'll be writing on it and so it'll be a
my big project so I think it's gonna be
great and you know please look for it
next fall another question yes
microphone
how is Monday's Wed rug defend Mondays
Wed raagh event was great and it was
Elda avalon and it was for it was
basically to answer to arnold
schwarzenegger 'he's you know vetoing
the gay marriage bill after it had
passed in the California Senate after it
passed in the assembly Arnold
Schwarzenegger vetoed the gay marriage
bill which is like I don't understand
why somebody who looks so gay is so
anti-gay
it's very frustrating the whole gay
marriage issue because the people that
are against gay marriage really are not
affected by gay marriage at all I mean
they wouldn't even know it's gays and
lesbians who were getting married if we
didn't tell them they would have no idea
it was happening and it it's just this
ideological debate and it's a waste of
time and it's it's so depressing the way
that people will hang on to homophobia
for so long they want to hang on to it
they say it's the ignorance that just
won't won't die they want to keep it
it's a it's like a security blanket for
the right-wing or something it's this
weird thing and I don't understand so
what rock was this great event where a
lot of people got together and raised
some money in order to just fight this
you know to get to get more energized
about this issue which I think is is
something that we need to deal with you
know and it's very important to me I
have a website called love is love is
love calm which is devoted to making
same-sex marriage a reality and it's a
great resource site where you know you
can go and get different information
about what's happening in your state and
you know but it's it's something that
means a lot to me because it's really
important and I'm married and you know
people think that's odd because I'm
married to a man and then they say well
why do you care so much about gay rights
and you know nobody no-nobody nowadays
questions the white students who went to
March with Martin Luther King and
Mississippi nobody thinks that that was
weird and so I hope to one day live in a
world where nobody is going to think
what I'm doing is weird like everybody's
gonna think that that's totally
acceptable and
I think it will someday no next question
yes for a comedy or political activism
who are your idols today who do you
aspire to be like who do you really
admire I admire a lot of different
people well in comedy probably my
favorite comedian is Wanda Sykes who is
a genius just and a visionary she's just
a remarkable person really funny and
also Dave Chappelle who I just adore and
I think that he is so smart and so
political and you know I miss his
television show I mean I think that he's
just great
and Chris Rock also those are probably
my favorite people in comedy and
politics politics I it really kind of
there's so many different people but you
know who really affected me I think the
whole reason I do this is when I was
very young I grew up in San Francisco
and I witnessed well I grew up during
the whole thing where Harvey Milk was
assassinated and Harvey Milk was the
first openly gay city elected official
and I was a big fan of his and and he
was assassinated and and it was so
devastating to me that somebody could be
killed basically because they're gay
that's just there's a there it's a very
complicated thing story but I mean to me
in my mind it was just because he was
gay that's why I was killed and I I
could not accept that as a child I
thought this has to change and I so I
wanted to do something about it and so
when I was very young I I just kind of
got involved with different things that
I I started doing comedy and I started
going to gay clubs and doing you know
fundraising for AIDS and and then you
know just kind of my political life grew
alongside my career and so the to me
they're very much connected and I think
that lately I've had more confidence to
be more forthright politically and be
more aggressive about my abuse but you
know I've always really I think I think
that Harvey Milk was always like my
favorite just because he was sort of
like
childlike I looked it up it up to I bet
him it's up to him so much when I was a
child so he was my favorite I liked
Howard Dean to know nowadays but so I
have a lot of people that I like anyway
yes right there when will we get to see
bamm-bamm until s okay bamm-bamm and
Celeste is a movie that I am made
it's a [ __ ] and [ __ ] sure and it's a
love story but you know because I think
that it's important to have that
relationship you know where because I
see it so many times in life where you
know you have the very kind of misfit
girl and you have as her gay boyfriend
and they have the best time together and
and so this is a story about them and
you know they go on a big road trip and
they go to New York to be on a reality
television show and and it's a beautiful
film and you know it's really hard to
sell this movie you know where we went
to the Toronto Film Festival and the
audiences really loved us and the
festival people they were great they
really loved the film but the critics
just didn't know what to do because when
they see an Asian person on screen and
they're not doing martial arts they
freak out like if I don't have [ __ ]
two guns chow yun-fat style they don't
know what to do so like that you know we
we just people
we're not like understanding what we
were trying to do like it's a comedy and
you know it's an independent film but
critics don't know they don't count it
as independent film if it's not told
backwards you know so it's like a really
hard thing to do when you know you
you're kind of you look to world's like
you look to all like alternative worlds
like independent film you think oh wait
this is gonna be an oasis if people are
gonna be really cool and they're not
it's just as racist and sexist
homophobic as anywhere else you know
it's just they're wearing cords though
so it's just that's the only difference
and it's really depressing things so you
know the movie is a it's it was in the
AFI festival this week and this Sunday
it'll be in it was screening on Saturday
in the AFI festival and then said
screening for fusion which is the gay
and lesbian people of color FileMaker
Festival which is really cool so those
are the two screening screening times
here in Southern California but I don't
know I mean it has yet to get
distribution and it's because this world
is very not accepting of queer cinema
not accepting a queer people color and
not accepting of all these things and
it's very hard because I think it's a
really good film but hard to sell
because of the very real problem of
racism and sexism and homophobia so but
it'll be out there soon I hope we'll see
anybody else right there
actually you mentioned the AFI festival
and I was wondering if you'd be doing a
Q&A along with the film I did the AFI
festival I did one on Tuesday night and
I actually will be in Minneapolis on
Saturday so I won't be there but I will
be there at the fusion screening on
Sunday anybody else right there yes hi
um this is kind of off topic but it's
just something that really bothers me I
was wondering how you felt on the new
proposition in Kansas about not teaching
evolution or denying evolution in
schools you know intelligent design
not that intelligent I mean it's so
stupid it's so incredibly stupid I mean
I think it's valid to say okay we can
teach the creation myth along with other
myths from cultures you know it's it's
valuable as like a historical idea but
don't teach it in like [ __ ] biology
class I mean don't tell yeah I mean
that's just so stupid it's like just why
are you trying to make our children as
dumb as you why it's so it makes me so
mad but intelligent design is that makes
me even madder than just flat-out
creationism like that that's just
intelligent design like [ __ ] you it's
not me could you imagine if you like you
know went in and like you know tried to
get goddess worship you kind of
established in a biology class or you
know if you do any other religion you
know like if you came in with a
pentagram and like some chicken blood or
whatever you know like just know we you
know I feel like my religion isn't be I
mean it's like so stupid you know that
kind of stuff makes me so mad I know
it's frustrating to meet you yes CSS
anybody else's right there's now a big
fan of yours and um you're welcome
and this is a statement not a question
but I don't have any credentials to
speak of but I've been a big big fan of
stand-up comedians you know my whole
life since I was a kid
and of all kinds of albums and I've
studied stand-up comedians I've been
lucky enough to see most of the
important ones and not to diminish any
of the accomplishments of the other
female comedians but in my opinion I
mean you are so far above and beyond
everybody else that that the way you
know the way things are the way things
work out fifty hundred years from now
when they list the ten greatest stand-up
comedians of all time there will only be
one woman on that list and you will be
that woman thank you I hope there'll be
lots of other women on that list I mean
because I always think women are so much
more funnier than men I mean I just I
just do I always laugh at the women I
they always you know because it's so
hard for a woman to do this to be in
this business you know this is the most
hostile place for for women because the
guy comics don't want you there because
we don't laugh at them we're not we're
like the only women that are not
impressed by funny guys you're just like
and they hate us for that because funny
guys is like they're so weird because
they they have one thing they can make
girls laugh and that's why they know
that they like they can compensate for
everything else all their other failings
and so they just want to stamp women out
women comics just never get a break and
it's so hard for us to survive and the
ones that do usually our lesbians
because they don't care what men think I
don't give a [ __ ] you know like and I
never cared what men think and it says
that that's sort of the only reason that
I survived but it was so was so hard so
I wish that there were more women in
this business and hopefully there will
be more in the future thank you I'm
better than all the men too right back
there yes it's you um we just wanted to
ask what got you interested in belly
dancing are you gonna be doing any more
well belly dancing is my favorite thing
in the world and I will be doing it as
long as I can do it because I love it so
so much and this is why I was this is
what happened I was in um you know
Glendale there's the Cairo carnival
every year Kyra Carnival is this thing
happens in June and it's at the
Glanville like a Civic Auditorium there
and Verdugo and it's so cool because it
has belly dancers from all over the
world they come and they dance and I
actually like went in there kind of by
accident I didn't know what it was and I
was so moved by all the women that I saw
there who were dancing who were having
such a good time who are beautiful who
are all different ages and we're talking
from like babies to women in their 80s
and women in their 80s wearing like
two-piece outfits like in a crown and it
celebrated women and that diversity it
was so beautiful that I had to
investigate I had to sort of figure out
what this was about and you know I went
into this world and I learned how to
dance and I learned how to be with women
because in our culture especially living
in Southern California women are so
conditioned to be competitive with one
another and therefore you don't have the
situation where usually in society that
women get to a certain age and they
mentor younger women and we don't really
have that in our culture because of the
way that this competition is set up
where older women are supposed to really
hate younger women and be threatened by
younger women and but that's not so in
belly dance and belly dance you look up
to your older women and the older women
take care of younger women and and you
learn to look at women's bodies without
a critical eye without saying oh my god
I'm fatter than her
oh my god I'm thinner than her um you
know like I wish I had this I wish I had
that it is it it is a totally new way of
looking at women's bodies which it was
so what I needed to do I mean as it you
know as a survivor of many years of
eating disorders of anorexia bulimia
everything after living with that
disease for so long and having such a
crazy kind of outlook and a skewed view
of women's bodies now I'm able to
appreciate women's bodies as they should
be and so you know Billie dance has
given me such an appreciation for women
it is truly where I found
feminism but where feminism is really
actively happening and women are
actually together and sharing and I love
it so much and it's weirded because
people think oh you're dancing for men
that it's some kind of weird seductive
dance for men to make your husband feel
like a sultan or something but it's not
that at all you know we're dancing for
other women and that's how it started it
was started for women dancing for women
in the harems and it's like kind of
growing out of that so it's a really
beautiful culture and and men are
welcomed into it you know there's a lot
of men dancers and it's so fun and you
know it's like my favorite teacher is 60
60 plus years old you know she's great
her name is Morocco she's so she's so
great and she's so such good shape
like and so beautiful and you know it's
incredible that something you know you
you know like some of the older women in
this business you know the they love
their bodies and that's so far into me
so it's a place where women are really
revered and I wish the whole world was
like that I'll take one more maybe yes
you've said it for many years that the
[ __ ] hags are the backbone of the gay
community and I'm just wondering if you
had any thoughts on the role of the Dyke
tyke in the lesbian community or in the
gay community in general are you
speaking of the Dutch boy no in the 70s
they called it a Dutch boy the Dutch boy
was a the straight man who hung around
with lesbians yes you know you must put
the finger in the Dyke the Dutch boy
very such that's so 70s and I think it's
great I think they're very natural
companions yeah I actually know a lot of
straight guys who hang around with
lesbians and I think that's beautiful I
mean I think it's it's it's a little bit
I always say that it's cool when
straight guys can like hang out with
queers anyway cuz I just I love that
then they they should be able to I mean
I don't know why I give them so much
credit for doing what should be natural
anyway but you know whenever a straight
guy does something kind of right I like
always going to oh yeah
maybe you will teach more of them yeah
but I think I think it's great you know
core community needs more alliances or
that that kind of Ally and I the the
core community needs more people who are
guess technically heterosexual who count
themselves in as queer because really if
you feel like an outsider in this
culture you're queer and the the faster
you realize that and stop being afraid
of that moniker that label the more
empowered you're going to be the quicker
you're going to actually like feel
somehow the majority you'll you'll
actually come into power so I encourage
that for everybody I would like to thank
you all so much for coming and I'll be
here I will take photographs I will sign
anything you want but thank you for
coming thanks a lot Margaret Cho is
author of I have chosen to stay in fight
it's published by Riverhead books visit
Riverhead books calm for more
information